[Musik]
es erscheint wie ein Wunder die Bergung
der kleinen Mirai heute morgen in der
türkischen Provinz adiaman und das 177
Stunden nach dem ersten Beben im
türkischen syrischen Grenzgebiet
gott ist groß jubeln die Umstehenden die
Retter versuchen jetzt auch noch mir
Reis ältere Schwester zu bergen auch in
anderen Regionen des erdbebengebietes
konnten heute noch mindestens sieben
weitere Menschen lebend aus den Trümmern
gezogen werden
guten Abend willkommen zum zdf-spezial
Wunder wie wir sie gerade gesehen haben
geschehen immer noch aber sie werden
seltener stetig steigt dagegen die Zahl
der Toten auf heute mehr als 37.000
doppelt so viele könnten es werden die
Überlebenden zu versorgen bleibt für
lange Zeit eine Riesenaufgabe wir
sprechen in dieser Sendung mit
erdbebenexperten die an einer besseren
Vorhersage von Erdbeben arbeiten mit
Helfern in der Türkei und in Syrien und
mit Betroffenen in Deutschland die um
Ihre Liebsten bangen und wir geben den
Menschen eine Stimme die all das durch
leiden müssen meine Kollegin Anne Brühl
war in der Stadt Iskenderun die das
Beben mit voller Wucht getroffen hat
hier ihr Bericht
Trümmer überall Trümmer es kennen darum
die alte Hafenstadt hat das Beben
besonders schlimm getroffen mitten in
all dem Chaos treffen wir Philipp
terbierley der überlebt hat
das kann man mit Worten nicht
beschreiben
ich kann es nicht erzählen ich kann es
jetzt nicht
eine große Angst wir haben große Angst
gehabt ich kann es nicht erzählen
Verwandtschaft haben wir nicht verloren
aber Nachbarn Freunde natürlich
viel ist nicht übrig geblieben in der
scänderrun das Zentrum voller Trümmer
über alles schon schweres Gerät im
Einsatz Leichen Geruch und jede Menge
Staub liegen über der Stadt und
zwischendrin all die Rettungsteams und
Freiwilligen die immer noch alles
versuchen Überlebende zu finden auch
nach sieben Tagen
wir sind sehr müde wir arbeiten 30 40
Stunden Schichten aber glaubt uns wir
sind immer noch motiviert wir graben
immer noch Überlebende aus natürlich
auch tote das können wir nicht ändern
die Stadt ist voller Militär und Polizei
der türkische Staat zeigt Stärke im
Erdbebengebiet
klauen während die Leute sterben
deswegen sind wir hier wegen der
Sicherheit
in den Trümmern liegen Schuhe auf der
Straße hier war mal ein Geschäft was wir
dann beobachten ist wohl eher ein
aktiver Verzweiflung Mustafa sucht nach
allem was er gebrauchen kann
noch was suchen Sie
ich brauche hilfe deswegen versuche ich
für meine Frau meine Kinder und mich
brauchbare Sachen zu finden wir nehmen
diese Sachen Hausschuhe Essen alles was
wir finden versuche ich mitzunehmen
am Rande der Stadt hat der türkische
Katastrophenschutz Zelte errichtet die
Schlange der Hilfsbedürftigen ist lang
Reset und Sultan korkmas gehören zu den
Glücklichen denen schon ein Zelt
zugewiesen wurde
unser Haus ist nicht komplett
eingestürzt aber es ist gefährlich
überhaupt reinzugehen wir haben Angst
reinzugehen wir waren in Not seit Tagen
verbringen wir die Nächte draußen
im Camp treffen wir auch spanische
Marine Soldaten die die Rettungsarbeiten
unterstützen auch Sie sind langsam am
Ende ihrer Kräfte
seid ihr hierfür speziell ausgebildet
nicht wirklich wenn du der Realität
begegnest musst du sie akzeptieren
noch weiß keiner wie viele Menschen hier
gestorben sind es gibt keine offiziellen
Zahlen nur Leid und Trauer der wir
überall begegnen
meine Tante wurde als letztes aus den
Truman rausgeholt sie war die letzte wir
haben sie danach begraben wir haben
alles verloren wir haben keine
Familienangehörigen mehr in den Häusern
können wir nicht mehr wohnen deshalb
wollen wir die Stadt verlassen und
woanders hingehen
Elif und ihre Familie sind geblieben ihr
Haus ist eingestürzt sie sind
rechtzeitig rausgekommen die Familie hat
einen Umzugsunternehmen sie schlafen
jetzt in einem der Lastwagen mit 12
Personen Elif zeigt uns alles und es ist
nachts
ja es wird sehr sehr kalt wir frieren
elif ist 11 ihre Mutter hat sie geweckt
im Arm gehalten als die Erde bebte
ja ich hatte große Angst unser Haus
stand in der Mitte von drei Gebäuden das
hat stark gebebt ich dachte die anderen
Gebäude stürzen auf uns
alle sind am Leben sie haben Glück
gehabt erzählt uns Elif Mutter aber
Glück das ist denn es kennen darum
relativ
ich bin traurig weil wir unsere alten
Nachbarn verloren haben
ich bin traurig weil wir Freunde von
meiner Tochter verloren haben
ich bin traurig weil meine Tochter jetzt
keine Ausbildung bekommt ich bin traurig
wegen unserer Wohnung mein Leid ist sehr
groß aber wir versuchen gut gelaunt zu
sein wegen der Kinder
und dann nimmt sie elef fest in den Arm
das Trauma der Überlebenden auch das
müssen sie in es kennen darum irgendwie
bewältigen
im Studio begrüße ich Anselm Stern der
sich für uns als Reporter direkt nach
dem Beben auf den Weg ins
Katastrophengebiet gemacht hat
willkommen herzlich willkommen hallo du
warst fünf Tage in kirikan in der Region
Hatay was hast du da erlebt also
Matthias man muss sagen die Lage dort
die ist wirklich schrecklich die
Menschen dort die haben nichts mehr die
die überlebt haben die haben nur noch
ihr Leben es gibt dort aktuell kein
Strom kein Wasser ähm es gibt auch sonst
sehr sehr sehr wenig und sie sitzen dort
vor den Trümmern ihrer Häuser in dem
Wissen dass in diesen Trümmern ganz ganz
viele Tote liegen ihre Freunde ihre
Familienmitglieder ihre Lieben das ist
natürlich eine schreckliche Situation
und ähm sie müssen wirklich gucken wie
Sie den Alltag überhaupt hinkriegen weil
sie beispielsweise ja überhaupt keinen
Haus mehr haben sie sitzen vor den vor
den Trümmern und halten sich mit feuern
warm wir sind morgens früh immer in die
Stadt gefahren und haben gesehen wie
diese Menschen sich versuchen mit Feuer
und warm zu halten da gab es eine fünf
köpfige Familie die hatte zwei bis
kaputte Decken also die Lage der
Menschen dort die ist wirklich
fürchterlich seine riesengroße Trauer
natürlich und ein sehr sehr schlimmer
schwieriger Alltag du warst ja mit
rettungsspezialisten unterwegs mit denen
du aus Deutschland schon reingeflogen
bist in das Krisengebiet wie hat das
Team gearbeitet also da muss ich sagen
Matthias kann ich nur mit riesengroßer
Hochachtung auf die Arbeit dieser
Menschen schauen mit einem riesengroßen
respekt das sind ja alles freiwillige
und ehrenamtliche Retter die sozusagen
von jetzt auf gleich alles stehen und
liegen lassen und in diese Katastrophe
fliegen und man muss auch sagen ihre
Arbeit dort die ist brandgefährlich denn
es ist so dass die allermeisten Häuser
dort in der Stadt in der wir waren in
der Region hathai einsturzgefährdet sind
und auch die Arbeit in den Trümmern es
wahnsinnig gefährlich der Einsatzleiter
der hat mir gesagt wenn man da den
falschen Stein wenn man da eine falsche
Platte rausnimmt dann kracht dieser
Trümmerhaufen natürlich ganz schnell
noch weiter zusammen man kann sich
vorstellen wenn man dann als Retter ganz
unten ist hat man keine Chance du hast
eine Rettungsaktion über 56 Stunden lang
begleitet wie ist das abgelaufen und wie
ist es ausgegangen ja das war wirklich
eine unglaubliche Rettungsaktion die
Retter haben mir gesagt oder waren sehr
sehr erfahrene Ärzte dabei die schon
überall waren auf der Welt dass sie
sowas noch nicht erlebt haben die Frau
war 100 Stunden eingeklemmt und 56
Stunden lief eben diese diese
Rettungsaktion es war unglaublich
kompliziert weil sich die Trümmerteile
auch immer wieder bewegt haben und das
war für die für die Einsatzkräfte
wirklich ein unglaublich belastender
Einsatz weil sie auf dem Weg zu dieser
Frau immer wieder auf Leichen getroffen
sind immer wieder Leichen gefunden haben
am Ende hat sich herausgestellt dass
diese Frau zusammen mit ihren toten
Kindern mit ihrem toten Mann da dort
unten lag sie haben es dann tatsächlich
geschafft sie rauszuholen lagen sich
weint in den Armen und ein paar Stunden
später kam die Nachricht dass diese Frau
sehr nett 40 Jahre alt im Krankenhaus
gestorben ist und das zeigt glaube ich
genau sehr viel wie schlimm das dauert
alles nach ein paar Tagen ist die
Stimmung gekippt von Trauer hin zu Wut
wie seid ihr damit umgegangen
das hat man finde ich wirklich gesehen
wie das von Tag zu Tag sich verändert
hat am Anfang haben wir eigentlich nur
in leere Trauernde Gesichter geschaut
dort in den Straßen und das wurde dann
immer aggressiver die Stimmung immer
lauter wurde ist da in den Straßen diese
bergungsstelle wo die wo die Frau war
und wo die Rettung so lange gedauert hat
da kamen wirklich immer mehr Menschen
die dann die Retter auch attackiert
haben verbal und angeschrieben haben
kommt doch auch zu uns hilft doch auch
uns
geschuldet natürlich einfach dieser
riesengroßen Verzweiflung und diese
Rettungsaktion die musste dann
tatsächlich auch abgesichert werden vom
türkischen Militär wie gehst Du um mit
all diesen Eindrücken das sind ja auch
Bilder die sich einbrennen ja ich glaube
die wird man auch nicht mehr wirklich
los wir haben natürlich da Leichen
gesehen wir haben da äh fürchterliches
Leid gesehen Menschen die wirklich
schreien und weinen und ich glaube ja
jeder geht dann am Ende des Tages
wahrscheinlich anders mit um ich muss
sagen für mich war das schlimmste
tatsächlich der letzte der letzte Tag
weil es da weil die dort angefangen
haben die Trümmer abzubaggern und es
wirklich überall ganz stark und schlimm
nach Leichen gerochen hat vielen Dank
für deine eindrucksvollen Schilderungen
komm gut wieder an und danke für den
Besuch im Studio herzlichen Dank
allein im Katastrophengebiet im Süden
der Türkei ist die Zahl der Toten auf
fast 30.000 gestiegen und noch immer
werden zahlreiche Opfer unter den
Trümmern befürchtet Präsident erdogan
will im Mai wieder gewählt werden sieht
sich jetzt aber mit immer größerer Wut
der Bevölkerung konfrontiert viel zu
spät und unzureichend habe er auf die
Katastrophe reagiert meinen viele
hinzukommen bohrende Fragen nach der
Bauweise im Erdbebengebiet Jörg Brase
berichtet
als vor einer Woche die Erde bebte la
caraman marashna dem Epizentrum weite
Teile der Stadt sind heute eine
Ruinenlandschaft ein Gebäude aber blieb
unbeschädigt es ist das örtliche
Hauptquartier der türkischen
stadtplanungs- und Architektenkammer die
Fachleute hatten dafür gesorgt dass ihr
Haus nach den staatlichen Vorschriften
für erdbebensicheres Bauen errichtet
wurde
sehen wir folgendes sehr deutlich
baufällige Gebäude wurden nicht geprüft
und selbst wenn sie geprüft wurden hat
man nicht die notwendigen Maßnahmen
ergriffen die Architekten kann man
konnten früher selbst bauprüfungen
vornehmen sagt Genschers Kollegin Pelin
Pina gerid doch diese Erlaubnis wurde
ihnen entzogen
hat jahrelang damit verbracht die
Befugnisse der Architektenkammer
einzuschränken sie haben Gesetze
erlassen die uns Zuständigkeiten
wegnahmen damit kämpfen wir seit Jahren
bauprüfungen wurden oft privaten
Unternehmen übertragen viele davon haben
offenbar einen schlechten Job gemacht
einer der führenden Geologen in der
Türkei ist Professor chillant chenga er
ärgert sich über schlechte Kontrollen
und sieht einen Grund dafür in der
wachsenden Korruption
erlaubt in der Türkei
das ist das ist das ist das große
Problem und was hinter dieser Problem
liegt ist der Ignoranz
denn welche Gebiete in Karaman Marash
bei einem Beben besonders gefährdet sind
war bekannt sagt schenger so hätten
Forscher Kollegen schon vor langer Zeit
eine Gefährdungskarte für die Stadt
gezeichnet wir haben diese Karte an
Herrn Bürgermeister geschickt die
Bürgermeister hat das angeguckt der hat
gesagt das nicht
und nicht gemacht
woher fand diese man diese Autorität zu
sagen dass er das nicht glaubt
über Jahre wuch so ein tödliches
Geflecht von Korruption
Ignoranz und krimineller Energie in der
Millionenstadt Adana zum Beispiel stürzt
nur wenige Gebäude ein sicher fühlen
sich die Anwohner trotzdem nicht
anstatt Beton haben sie Sand benutzt
derselbe Bauherr hat auch diese Häuser
hier gebaut deshalb gehen wir nicht rein
es ist viel zu gefährlich
in Adana werden einsturzgefährdete
Gebäude nun kontrolliert abgerissen es
sind Sandburgen die hier zusammenstürzen
die türkische Regierung verspricht
durchzugreifen einige Bauunternehmer
wurden festgenommen gegen andere wird
ermittelt Maßnahmen die längst
überfällig sind
und dann gibt es noch die fatale
bauamnestie
illegal errichtete Gebäude konnten
nachträglich gegen Zahlung einer Strafe
legalisiert werden das spülte Milliarden
in die Staatskasse was erdbebenexperten
zur Weißglut bringt dem gab der
Präsident damals den schönen Namen
baufreden
wir wollen einen Konflikt zwischen
unseren Bürgern mit dem Staat lösen ich
hoffe dass mindestens die Hälfte der
Betroffenen Gebäude vom baufrieden
profitieren werden aber wir werden nicht
erlauben dass irgendjemand damit
Schindluder treibt
doch es wurde Schindluder mit der Bau
Amnestie getrieben denn viele Gebäude
wurden nie überprüft allein im
Erdbebengebiet wurden rund 300.000
illegal errichtete Häuser im Rahmen der
Amnestie legalisiert
alle schönen Pläne alle Regeln aller
umsetzungsvorschriften werden dann
absolut die Bauamt lässt ihn haben dazu
geführt dass etliche Gebäude die nicht
erdbebensicher sind einen rechtlichen
Status erhalten haben
so trägt die Regierung eine mit Schuld
an der Katastrophe weil sie nicht
verhinderte dass ihre Bürger in
kartenhäusern lebten
und in Potsdam spreche ich jetzt mit
Professor Thorsten Dahm vom Institut für
Geowissenschaften guten Abend guten
Abend warum ist die Türkei für Erdbeben
so besonders exponiert
in der Türkei stoßen mehrere tektonische
Platten aneinander die sich mit relativ
hoher Geschwindigkeit gegeneinander
bewegen und an den Plattenrändern
sogenannten Plattengrenzen können sich
dadurch Spannungen mechanische
elastische Spannungen aufbauen und diese
bauen sich dann immer wieder in größeren
zeitlichen Abständen doch Erdbeben ab
Istanbul gilt ja auch seit Jahren als
hoch gefährdet wie schätzen Sie die
Erdbebengefahr für die
Millionenmetropole ein
ja Istanbul oder man muss sagen
insgesamt die Ost anatolische
Verwerfungszone also Plattengrenze wo
jetzt die Erdbeben stattgefunden haben
genauso wie die nordanatolische
Verwerfung an der Istanbul liegt tragen
eine hohe seismische Gefährdung das weiß
man vor allem durch die Auswertung von
seismischen Katalogen und von
historischen Beben und in Istanbul ist
diese Gefährdung eben auch zusätzlich
noch besonders signifikant weil die
Region nicht besiedelt ist und natürlich
auch viele alte Gebäude in dieser
Millionenstadt und Metropolregionen
existieren die eventuell Schaden nehmen
beim starken Beben viele hoffen ja jetzt
bei der Erdbebenforschung auf die
künstliche Intelligenz wie weit sind wir
da aus ihrer Sicht und was kann die
leisten
ja ein Ansatz in der Erdbebenforschung
ist es möglichst kleine Beben zu
detektieren und diese auszuwerten aus
der Statistik dieser kleinen Beben
glaubt man dann oder versucht etwas zu
lernen über die Eigenschaften von
verwerfungszonen und letztlich dann auch
über große Erdbeben und dazu muss man
zum einen sei es mische Netze aufbauen
das Geoforschungszentrum Potsdam hat
auch ein seistisches Netz in der Region
um Istanbul aufgebaut zum anderen
benötigt man dann aber auch entsprechend
moderne Verfahren die in der Lage sind
ganz kleine Erdbeben zu detektieren und
zu lokalisieren und da kommt die
künstliche Intelligenz ins Spiel die
kann helfen auch kleinen Ereignisse zu
detektieren was glauben Sie wie kann es
gelingen Erdbeben passgenauer und mit
genügend Vorlauf vorherzusagen
ja Erdbeben auf den Tag den Ort und die
Stärke vorhersagen können wir leider
nicht dazu das geht deshalb nicht weil
es keine verlässlichen
vorläuferphänomene gibt die man
beobachten kann zum Beispiel könnten
kleine Erdbeben solche
vorläuferphänomene sein aber leider
treten diese sogenannten Vorbeben nicht
verlässlich vor allem stark Beben auf
ja vielen Dank für das Gespräch nach
Potsdam gerne
auch in den syrischen Erdbebengebieten
ist die Lage katastrophal schon vor der
Katastrophe lebten hier Millionen
Flüchtlinge in großem Elend und in
baufälligen Unterkünften jetzt graben
sie mit bloßen Händen nach Verschütteten
und fühlen sich von der Welt vergessen
Barbara Luke beginnt ihren Bericht in
sarmada im Nordwesten des Landes an der
Grenze zur Türkei
alles zerstört nichts ist übrig ein Ort
ohne Horizont aber für abdelmon im Kasse
mal rasuk der das Erdbeben überlebte ist
es eine ganze Welt seine Welt in samada
im Nordwesten Syriens die nicht mehr da
ist er verlor 13 Menschen und das hier
ist der Platz ihnen nahe zu sein
ich bin hier um mich zu erinnern so
viele Erinnerungen sind hier ich sehe
das Kleid meiner Schwester die Kleidung
Ihres Sohnes ihr Geruch ist hier so
viele Erinnerungen
samada im Nordwesten Syriens vor den
Rebellen kontrolliert über allen
Menschen die sich vergessen fühlen vom
Rest der Welt sie graben in Trümmern und
warten auf Wunder
babalhauer der einzige Grenzübergang der
offen ist um über 4 Millionen Menschen
in der gesamten Region zu helfen am
Wochenende überqueren rund 20 LKWs mit
Hilfsgütern der Vereinten Nationen den
Grenzübergang Decken Verbandszeug
Medizin es reicht hinten und vorne nicht
die ganze Welt hat uns im Stich gelassen
wenn es so eine Katastrophe in Europa
oder anderswo gegeben hätte die ganze
Welt hätte sich versammelt um zu helfen
sie haben auf uns gebäumt niemanden hat
das interessiert niemand fragt nach uns
es kümmert keinen
in dem kleinen Krankenhaus nahe des
Grenzübergangs liegen verwundete ihre
Verletzungen sind schwer Ärzte und
Pfleger arbeiten Tag und Nacht ihre
Ausrüstung ist erbärmlich ihre Wut
grenzenlos
ich fragte einen Vertreter der
Hilfsorganisation nach medizinische
Ausrüstung und er antwortete wir haben
Leichensäcke für euch das war alles mehr
kam nicht sie wissen dass die Menschen
hier ohne Hilfe sterben ihr einziges
Recht das sie haben ist zu sterben dafür
haben wir dann die Leichensäcke
Menschen die übrig blieben die
politische Konflikte auf großer
Weltbühne büßen müssen die sehen das
internationale Hilfe in die Türkei und
in Regime kontrollierte Gebiete kommt
nur hierher kommt niemand
Dave
tagelang haben wir Menschen in den
Trümmern gehört Menschen die uns
angebettelt haben ihre Leben zu retten
aber wir konnten es nicht wir haben
keine Ausrüstung die Vereinten Nationen
müssen verantwortlich gemacht werden für
das was uns Syrern passiert ist dafür
uns im Stich zu lassen dafür dass sie
Menschen haben sterben lassen weil wir
keine Hilfe haben
vergessen verloren in Idleb stehen sie
still auf den Trümmern und protestieren
gegen die UN gegen die Untätigkeit der
Welt am Ende gegen Unmenschlichkeit ein
paar Meter weiter liegt ein Schild auf
den Steinen ihre Schreie verstummten
hier steht da
in Syrien sind wir jetzt verbunden mit
Mahmut dahi der mit seinem Münchner
vereinseiten neun Jahren Flüchtlingen an
der türkisch-syrischen Grenze hilft
guten Abend ja hallo guten Abend sie
haben ja in den vergangenen Tagen in der
Türkei geholfen und sind seit heute in
Syrien wie ist denn die Situation vor
Ort
also ich war jetzt auf dem Weg in die
Türkei es ist wirklich also dramatisch
so jetzt bin ich sehr viel Tage
unterwegs ich habe versucht nach Syrien
zu
fahren es ist nicht möglich die
Genehmigung ist es sehr sehr schwer nach
Syrien zu kommen nach vier Tage habe
Gott sei Dank heute eine Genehmigung
bekommen und ich bin seit sechs Jahren
sechs Stunden jetzt hier in auf die
jüdischen Worten ich bin in genderis
gewesen aber am schlimmsten Erdbeben
getroffen als es wirklich dramatisch
aber sag's ihnen es ist niemanden da die
Leute die Einheimischen haben sie ihr
Leid selber getragen
[Musik]
und irgendein Land nicht warum ist es
denn so schwierig Hilfe nach Syrien zu
bringen
ja weil die sagen also dort ist
Kriegsgebiets dann dürfen niemanden
rüber erst mal weil warum ich selber als
Syrer habe ich vier Tage gebracht dass
ich überhaupt rein dürfen ich bin Syrer
ja wollte ich einen deutschen
Staatsbürger bin aber ich habe einen
deutschen syrischen Pass auch habe ich
nicht einmal vier Tage gesucht Ich
wollte den Leuten ich habe den Türken
gesagt ich will nur helfen ja nein gibt
nicht was können sie denn konkret vor
Ort tun
ich kann nur Leute hier mal selber also
wenn Material kommt wir können dann die
die begrabung richtig machen es gibt
noch viele Tote noch unter den Trümmern
ist niemanden will helfen keine Ahnung
warum
wir erleben Sie denn persönlich diese
Katastrophe was machen diese Bilder mit
ihnen und diese Zusammentreffen mit den
Menschen
begraben nicht die lebendigen die
wendigen haben wir jetzt einen richtigen
Lager gerichtet na dass wir paar
Familien die überleben haben hier mal
eine Unterkunft haben 30 km von den
richtigen Erdbeeren von
Günters aber ich kann ich bin eine
Person
50 60 Familien übernehmen das ist eine
staatenaufgabe
Menschen über 30
.000 Tote in einen Stille
ja da hier wir spüren ihre Wut und auch
ihre Verzweiflung und ich danke Ihnen
sehr für dieses Gespräch
vielen Dank
das Gespräch haben wir kurz vor der
Sendung aufgezeichnet
mehr als 23 Millionen Menschen sind von
den verheerenden Beben betroffen
schätzen Experten auch in Deutschland
ist der Schock und die trauergroß hier
leben viele Türken oder Deutsch Türken
mit teils engen Verbindungen in die
Heimat überall packen Sie jetzt mit an
um den Erdbebenopfern zu helfen in
Vereinen in Nachbarschaftshilfen mit
Spendenaktionen
Ihlow und Birgit heisicke mit einem
Beispiel aus Niedersachsen
sie backen viel in diesen Tagen in den
türkischen Gemeinden die türkische Pizza
wird nach den muslimischen
Gottesdiensten verkauft das Geld sofort
gespendet an Hilfsorganisationen viele
hier haben Angehörige verloren im
Erdbebengebiet leider Gottes leben auch
einige von uns drüben die Eltern
einige sind leider auch umgekommen ne ja
unsere Freundinnen und das ist schon
sehr traurig dass wir von hier leider
nur das machen können was was wir gerade
hier machen Spenden und gemeinsam beten
sie rufen auf zu Geld spenden das sei im
Moment die effektivste Art zu helfen
neben der Seelsorge die sie in den
Gemeinden gerade leisten müssen wir
haben eine Familie hier in Wolfenbüttel
die 23
Familienangehörige verloren hat
das ist eine Frau eine Dame die auch
nicht in die Krisenregion reisen kann um
Abschied zu nehmen
weil sie hat dafür nicht die Kraft viele
türkischstämmige Menschen in
Wolfenbüttel haben Angehörige Freunde
und Bekannte in der Katastrophenregion
zwischen der Türkei und Syrien verloren
einige wissen noch nicht wie es ihren
Verwandten geht das Spenden ist ihre
einzige Möglichkeit zu helfen jeden Tag
gibt es Aktionen in der türkischen
Gemeinde auch über die Gemeindegrenzen
hinaus ist die Unterstützung groß die
Hilfsbereitschaft ist natürlich ganz
enorm wir kriegen ganz viele Anfragen in
der Verwaltung und man sieht einfach
dass es uns im gegenseitig im
einzunehmen das sind ja unsere
wolfenbüttelalterinnen und Bürger und
Bürger wichtig ist dass wir
zusammenkommen und einfach unsere
Anteilnahme hier bekunden
Toten Gebete in den Moscheen
Organisation von Sachspenden und Geldern
in allen Moschee Gemeinden in
Deutschland wird getrauert
in der ganzen Tragödie was uns Hoffnung
gibt ist der Zusammenhalt und die
Solidarität der Menschen nicht nur unter
dem Muslimen sondern allgemein in der
Gesellschaft viele hier wollten schon
aufbrechen in die Türkei ins
Erdbebengebiet um zu helfen doch die
Reise dahin ist schwierig Deutschland
verspricht nun die unbürokratische
Einreise verangehörige aus den
Erdbebengebieten ein kleiner Trost die
muslimischen Gemeinden raten weiter zu
spenden ich denke es kommt erstmal nicht
drauf an jetzt viel zu spenden sondern
das ganze auf die lange Bank das
gespendet wird weil das Ausmaß des
Erdbebens ist können wir von hier noch
gar nicht beurteilen ich habe mit Leuten
gesprochen die aktuell dort sind um zu
helfen die sagen das ist was ihr gesehen
habt ist vielleicht ein Bruchteil davon
wie es hier quasi aussieht
sie hoffen dass die Solidarität und die
Hilfe anhalten das Ausmaß dieser großen
Katastrophe wird eine Herausforderung
bleiben für eine lange Zeit
die Hilfsorganisation stelp aus
Baden-Württemberg unterstützt Menschen
in akuter Not ihren Gründer Serkan Ehren
erreichen wir in Hatay 200 Kilometer vom
Epizentrum des Bebens entfernt guten
Abend
guten Abend hallo wie stellt sich denn
die Lage heute bei ihnen da wie ist die
Situation
ja allmählich geht man so in die in die
zweite Phase über eine Woche nach einer
Katastrophe ist dann irgendwie ist dann
oft so dass ja dass dieses Chaos nicht
legt bzw besser gesagt dass man sich an
den Chaos gewöhnt und die Leute richten
sich jetzt ja ein in die nächste Phase
in die langfristige Situation sie planen
wie sie jetzt demnächst eben leben
werden die Katastrophe wird ja ihre
Spuren nach sich ziehen und zwar lange
Zeit
über Millionen von Menschen haben ihre
Wohnungen verloren und leben aktuell auf
der Straße das ist ja auch wahnsinnig
kalt da das haben sie ihm Vorgespräch
schon gesagt haben denn mittlerweile
wenigstens alle ein Zeltdach über dem
Kopf und Decken zum wärmen
leider nicht also Decken mittlerweile
viele noch nicht alle Zelte bei weitem
nicht alle es ist ein großes Problem
weil es super super kalt ist wie gesagt
wir sehen hier Leute die wirklich
zittern vor uns stehen um um Hilfe
bitten ja sie hatten ja selbst ein
schwierigen Weg da rein in dieses
Erdbebengebiet können Sie noch mal kurz
erzählen aber was können sie denn
konkret tun um die Not zu lindern
also anfangs die ersten zwei drei Tage
haben wir uns tatsächlich auf Decken
konzentriert das war das wichtigste die
Leute sind teilweise in Schlaf also in
Unterwäsche und im Schlafanzug vor uns
gestanden weil ja wie man weiß ist es
ist ist passiert dann ist vor allem
Decken mittlerweile konzentrieren wir
uns auf Zelte und auf Container was die
Unterkunft angeht und was Hilfsgüter
angeht vor allem auch Babynahrung
Windeln Wasser natürlich sie haben ja
viele Schicksale von Menschen in Not
schon gesehen und auch oft helfen können
was macht die Situation jetzt nach dem
schweren Leben für sie so besonders
ja wie sie sagen ich habe einiges erlebt
es waren Afghanistan ich war im Osten
der Ukraine letztes Jahr eine lange Zeit
hier ist es so dass wir ja es ist schwer
ist schwer in Worte zu fassen ich selbst
musste
tote Kinderleichen aus dem sümern Ziehen
haben unzählige leichten gesehen die
einfach auf der Straße lagen die die
einzige Schicksale das ist das was einem
immer am meisten wird wir haben hier
ganz viele also ja es gibt hier
niemanden der der keinen Freund oder er
hängt oder Verwandten verloren hat es
ist es ist eine einzige Katastrophe das
Problem ist auch dass wir hier von dem
Einzugsgebiet von der Größe der
Bundesrepublik sprechen das heißt die
Hilfe hier zu koordinieren ist fast
unmöglich ja es ist super schlimm also
nach jedem Einsatz liegen wir uns Helfer
also während des Einsatz funktioniert
doch recht gut aber nach den einsetzen
liegen wir uns buchstäblich weinten in
den Armen und versuchen selbst das
Erlebte irgendwie ähm
verarbeiten gibt es denn sowas wie
Hoffnung auf einen Wiederanfang da
also es gibt Städte die sind die sind ja
die existieren nicht mehr also wie hier
am Tag ja in der Stadt in der ich gerade
bin in der Region Hatay die hat
besonders schwer getroffen es gibt kaum
ein Gebäude das noch steht und die
Häuser die noch stehen sind ein
schutzgefährdet ich kann mir nicht
vorstellen oder ich oder ich weiß nicht
wie hier noch irgendwas funktionieren
soll oder dass die Stadt irgendwie noch
mal aufgebaut werden soll ähm die Leute
werden tatsächlich mit wussten
rausgeschickt herausgefahren also ich
weiß es nicht ich habe ich habe sowas
nie erlebt vielen Dank für das Gespräch
und weiterhin viel Erfolg mit ihrer
Arbeit die so vielen hilft danke vielen
Dank danke schön
es sind albtraumhafte Stunden und Tage
die die Menschen in den
Katastrophengebieten erlebt haben
Menschen die um ihre Liebsten bangen
Menschen die alles verloren haben die
frieren traumatisiert sind auf Hilfe
warten nach indouan und Martin Honecker
haben über Tage Stimmen von ihnen
gesammelt aus Syrien und aus der Türkei
hallo mein Name ist
saluch ich bin Journalistin aus Aleppo
heute ist Tag 7 seit dem Erdbeben
die Situation ist Menschen schlafen
immer noch in ihren Autos hier überall
wie man sehen kann
und die Leute sind hier überall im Park
es ist wirklich katastrophal
sie hat ihr zu Hause verlassen jetzt
lebt sie in diesem Zelt sie hat keine
Decken ihre Kinder sind auch da sie
haben keine Jacken keine Schuhe sie sind
bei dem Erdbeben einfach rausgerannt
hier die Bilder zeigen am besten wie die
Menschen leiden besser als ich das
überhaupt beschreiben kann mir fehlen
die Worte dafür
ist eine Moschee in Sheikh moushut hier
schlafen die Leute in der Moschee
zu
ich habe meine Frau und meine zwei
Kinder genommen und bin nach schermik
100 km entfernt von dir aber kill
gegangen
warum habe ich das gemacht ungefähr 70%
der Menschen sind in die Dörfer im
Umland von dir aber kurz zurückgegangen
dort stehen in der Regel einstöckige
Häuser während den die aber Kirche
Hochhäuser stehen
deswegen sind die Menschen aufs Land
oder in die ländliche Umgebung
zurückgegangen
[Musik]
wir fahren jetzt quasi in die Stadt rein
aber du siehst ja hier auch Sammelpunkte
siehst du
hier wird Essen verteilt die ersten drei
Tage war ja Chaos da haben die Menschen
unter sich versucht zu helfen jetzt
Polizei ist da milka ist da es wird
geholfen aber es ist halt schleppend ne
diese Wohnung stehen zwar aber halt
Frage ist wie lange noch ne das
schlimmste war also hier ereignen sich
auch Tragödien ne also das was wir
gesehen und gehört haben viele sind
beim zweiten Leben umgekommen
die sind wieder in die Wohnung rein da
war ja irgendwie 9 Stunden eine
Differenz zwischen den Beben da sind
halt auch leider viele Menschen die
liegen halt noch unter den Trümmern wir
sind Häuser die sind noch nicht mal
angerührt worden da gibt es gute
Nachrichten in anderen Regionen hier in
elbis dann seit drei Tagen keine gute
Nachricht ja also wir waren auch vor dem
Krankenhaus
ich habe mich also ich traute mich nicht
da reinzugehen weil da waren halt noch
knapp 300 Leichen die da gewartet haben
ne zum Bergen
da haben wir keine Macht oder keine
Kraft es ist halt wirklich sehr kalt da
mussten Profis dran und jetzt so seit
drei Tagen ist sie halt alles so die
Leute suchen halt nicht mehr nach
Überlebenden sondern
siehst du die Zerstörung aber hier wird
halt klar hier wird nicht mehr
gearbeitet also hier liegen noch
Menschen nur
es wird halt mit der Zeit aufgeräumt
zugeschaltet ist jetzt Kaya Yanar als
Comedian und Moderator bekannt wir
erreichen ihn in Zürich guten Abend
guten Abend sie haben viele Verwandte im
Erdbebengebiet in der zerstörten Stadt
Antakya wie geht es ihnen dort
also den Verwandten geht es den
Umständen entsprechend ich will nicht
sagen gut aber zumindest die Lage
stabilisiert sich
einige Verwandte Herren noch in Zelten
aus und kümmern sich um die Verwandten
die nicht überlebt haben also in der
Großfamilie zählen wir jetzt acht
verstorbene und
der Rest der Großfamilie hat sich quasi
verteilt also wir haben die Verwandten
sind verteilt im Inland und im Ausland
meine Mutter hat in Antalya eine
Ferienwohnung organisiert wo jetzt die
in einer Dreizimmerwohnung mit 16
Verwandten verwalt aber das ist alles
gut das ist alles Luxus Luxusproblem ist
einfach wirklich großartig dass es
Möglichkeiten gibt momentan zu helfen
und sich zu organisieren denn ähm auch
wenn der Großteil der Familie überlebt
hat so ist halt die Problematik wie es
jetzt weitergeht weil am Tag erst
einfach auf
was fühlen Sie Herr Jana sozusagen aus
der Ferne angesichts dieser Tragödie für
so viele Menschen
also wenn
wenn es wenn ich mal eine Pause habe
nachdem ich mich um meine Verwandten
gekümmert habe in meiner Mutter zusammen
dann erreiche mich natürlich Nachrichten
von allen anderen die in Mitleidenschaft
gezogen wurden es sind ja nicht nur
10.000 die verstorben sind sondern es
ist eine Million die Mitleidenschaft
gezogen wurden und
Nachrichten aus Syrien die sind einfach
herzzerreißend wenn jetzt ein Kind
wieder mal gerettet wird wo ich jetzt
sagen muss anscheinend ziehen die Helfer
gerade wieder ab das ist natürlich dann
eine ganz besondere Frage wenn man weiß
es wird jetzt niemand mehr gerettet
werden dass macht einfach schon fertig
also schon einige schlaflose Nächte
gehabt was hören sie denn von Verwandten
und Freunden was wird im
Katastrophengebiet jetzt am dringendsten
gebraucht
ja simple Sachen ganz viele leben immer
noch in Zelten also Sanitäranlagen
fließendes Wasser das sind so Dinge die
man Strom Elektrizität das sind Dinge
die halt
immer noch nicht wirklich gibt ja jetzt
nur so in so kleinen Orten wo man helfen
kann aber die ganze Stadt ist einfach
zerstört und ja die Leute sind halt
total verzweifelt also meine Mutter
berichtet mir von meinen Verwandten die
die das sind auch Kinder die dann
einfach nachts aufschreiben weil sie
total traumatisiert sind also das kommt
ja auch noch deshalb auch wenn du
überlebt hast gibt's noch so viele
Probleme die auf sich warten von der
Psychologie angefangen bis hin zu
simplen Dingen die Sanitäranlagen
fließend Wasser und so weiter also die
Probleme fangen jetzt an die
Spendenbereitschaft hier die ist ja
immer noch sehr sehr groß wie kann den
Menschen vor Ort denn langfristig am
besten geholfen werden
erdbebensicheres Bauen mehr zum Beispiel
ganz gut das ist ein bisschen schwierig
umzusetzen in der Türkei gibt es dieses
Gesetz schon seit knapp 20 Jahren aber
es gibt halt Push am Bau Korruption und
was weiß ich nicht alles ich bin da
keine Experte aber man sieht das einige
Häuser tatsächlich noch stehen in Antrag
erinnert und andere die meisten sind
leider im Erdboden gleich gemacht wie
man das jetzt anfängt also die türkische
Regierung hat Soforthilfe versprochen
also nicht nur monetär sondern halt auch
die Stadt schnell wieder aufzubauen ich
weiß nicht wie das so schnell geht ich
hoffe natürlich dass das das beste aber
das wäre zumindest mal ein guter Anfang
dass man sich halt auch gewisse Bauweise
verlassen kann so dass die Leute ja auf
gewisse baustande als verlassen kann so
dass die Leute in Ruhe wieder
zurückkehren können aber ich weiß
wirklich nicht wie schnell das geht und
ob das in diesem Ausmaß auch schnell
passieren kann
vielen Dank für das Gespräch und ihre
auch sehr persönlichen Eindrücke Kaya
Yanar sehr gerne
wenn sie den Menschen in Syrien und der
Türkei helfen wollen können Sie beim
Aktionsbündnis Katastrophenhilfe Spenden
IBAN
de65-100-400
600-100-400
Stichwort ZDF Erdbeben Türkei Syrien das
können Sie auch in Ruhe nachlesen unter
spenden.zdf.de oder im ZDF Text auf
Seite 890
in der syrischen Stadt Aleppo die über
viele Kriegsjahre im Bombenhagel lag
sagen sie so schlimm wie das Beben war
bisher nichts besser kann man die
verheerende Kraft dieser
Naturkatastrophe kaum in Worte fassen
Millionen Menschen werden über lange
Zeit von Hilfe abhängig sein die
Spendenbereitschaft in Deutschland ist
nach wie vor groß das ist gut und
wichtig vielen Dank für Ihr Interesse
auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]